hallo leute ich sie teure mal waren und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge ich
teste einer bildkalender und heute teste
ich feyzabad kaletta meine creams ellis
torten welt hat einen adventskalender
ausgebracht und ich habe ich ungefähr
vor drei wochen bestellt heute kam er an
und ich bin so gespannt was drin ist als
ich nämlich den amazon events könnten
ausgepackt hat mir jemand in die
kommentare geschrieben dass sie dieses
jahr auch ein gemacht hat nicht direkt
selbst sondern mit der firma rent muss
ich glaub berlin machen boxen ich bin
mir nicht ganz sicher auf jeden fall ist
das keine werbung ich wurde nicht
bezahlt ich habe schon über 40 ocken für
dieses ding hingeblättert und möchte
jetzt einfach wissen was drin ich habe
absolut keine ahnung was mich erwartet
ich hoffe dass ich ein paar verliess
toren welt produkte bekommen denn ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich bin ein großer
fan von ihrem merge der aus partikeln
besteht dass ich den selbst gestellt
habt solltet ihr jetzt vielleicht lieber
wegschalten damit ihr euch nicht
spoilern für alle anderen viel spare ich
liebe ihn jetzt schon aber er ist viel
zu groß für meine kleine wohnung und
falls sie das ist sally hay ich bin ein
großer fan seiner arbeit wirklich tolle
torten oh mein gott wenn ich irgendwann
mal im reallife treffen würde wäre das
es so orth wird
ich habe ja so respekt davor wenn
zuschauer auf mich zukommen weil ich das
selber nie könnte wenn ich sie irgendwo
auf der straße sehen würde
ich würde einfach schnappatmung bekommen
weiter gehen dies hätten darüber ein ok
oh ich habe die leute dieses jahr mit
müsli riegel ganz ehrlich die
live-rechte kartenflut
richterin revel ich habe schon eine
vermutung in welche richtung das jetzt
gehen wird wahrscheinlich sind hier
keine sally produkte drin das ist ja
viel besser sherbini nummer zwei
marmelade ich bin nicht undankbar ich
habe dafür selbst gezahlt okay ich bin
jetzt ein ehrlicher kritiker ich hab
dich hier das ist im pop die produkte
vielleicht hätte ich besser leben so
sind drei ist ja auch eine leckere hat
wenn es zeit ist klar dass kingsley
zeugnis ich werde okay als ich das
gerade gesehen ob das dieses normal
puderzucker aber das ist cacau
puderzucker auch ideal zum backen
verfeinern und die kuriere man rührt es
einfach mit wasser anderen hat dann lass
uns doch mal innovativ und cool ich habe
alles auf mich so zu beschweren
immer mehr typ 1300 eignet sich
besonders gut für brötchen brote und
eine kleine info card 1000 gramm kosten
2 euro 50 und ron carter okay jetzt wird
hier ganz interessant mit echter vanille
zucker mit gemalert tonkabohne fährt sie
mehr
also ich entdecke hier ganz neues euro
nikolaus womit überrascht und sally an
nikolaus mit teddy herr peek & the city
sieht immer sehr schön natural fair und
lässt das ist ein schöner gewürzten mit
zimt ingwer schwarzem pfeffer und
natürlichen zitronenaroma vermisse immer
noch ein bisschen warten welt produkte
falls ihr nicht wisst was ich meine ich
dachte da sind solche sachen drin das
ist vanille extrakt von salis torten
weil das hab ich mir letztens gekauft
für fünf euro
das war ganz schön teuer aber ich hatte
keine lust
immer diese tüten zu benutzen türchen
713 nicht inkagold an der honig etwas
besonderes heute ist internationaler tag
des honigs und honig freunde weltweit
feiern das flüssige gold erschienen hier
auch mal die preise oder wir hier stehen
auch immer die preise da bin ich mal
gespannt was am ende wert ist momentan
nicht das gefühl dass der 45 euro wert
ist oder 50 hat er gekostet aber sind ja
noch nicht durch
wir sind noch nicht durch
ich hoffe doch mal vor die macht morgens
als kalender auf wie sollte so schön auf
standen auch was da heute sein zweites
kalender dritter wurde wieder aus der eu
schon fertig in würfel geschnitten ich
kenne ja schon mal sagen dieser
rennkalender den weg für ihre mode 9
ich meine da muss sagen das sind bis
jetzt keine proben drin ist ist
eigentlich daniel heißt backen backen
ist liebe stimme zwar vor wenn man so
für den partner oder einer freundin
adventskalender sagt und hat einfach
immer ein typ und da warst du das
morgens zu hause
danke und nutzen die kenne ich die ist
so lecker weit nobert christiane
schokolade wirklich große empfehlung lpk
nuss kerne diesen teur 439 für 100 gramm
das ist echt krass jetzt krieg' hier
sind immer rezepte dabei ich konnte mich
einfach durch die rezepte nicht
gewaltsam rezepte dabei aber ganz ohr 12
die süßkartoffel mail da gibt es doch
bestimmt noch süßkartoffel genau che mit
sally du hast das ruder wieder
rumgerissen toll blutig präsent wir
waren bei der nummer drei
da sollte etwas bringt soft skills oft
nicht kennt ich liebe es oft faktisches
wie vor made from richtig coole typ i
sleep du hast dich wieder in der 14
nuss nougat schmelzende schokolade
kinokarten trüffel kleben an bank daraus
machen 15
veganer bio zitronenschale war 129 also
es muss ja am ende wenigstens der
einkaufspreis drin sein obwohl der 24
produkten wird alles zwei euro kostet
dann hat man schon den einkaufspreis
drin honig senf 279 dort man wird
wahrscheinlich den einkaufspreis wieder
kriegen winter salat mit
karamellisierter birne und honig senf
dressing gries ich bin gespannt 17
die kleine freche freunde 100% apfel und
blaubeer es riecht irgendwie künstlich
irgendwie auch nicht
die schon mal getrocknete blaubeere
gegessen
irgendwie nichts aber doch ein bisschen
schlecker sprechen freundin gibt es
keine 17 18
algen trecker wenn wir man sushi sehen
halt aus wie ganz normale cracker ich
finde fast nur in sushi oder haben so
bestimmt mega gesund 19
bio winter gewürzt zauber gewürzmischung
gewürzgurken über plätzchen bis nice
dream oder heiße getränke aus zimt anis
nelken kardamom ingwer spaß kostet 289
super wanzl getrockneter gemüse max grün
220 hirsch tomaten zucchini und zwiebel
auch hier dass es mir eines major das
schmeckt wie eine fette was zwiebeln
wurden
ich würde es auf jeden fall eines
topping benutzen ich mir ehrlich gesagt
nicht wo ich das drauf machen würde
müsliriegel
das ist man in polen ganz viel und so
kann man realisierte sie samen krieger
sonst noch kindheit und ultra schwer zu
kauen 22 barbecues hof vor sich hat ich
hab dir source warcraft heimlich
verstehen leute diese scharf essen
23 ein tag vorbei
ttt bio kräuter tee kindisch dieser tee
entführt dich nach indien geil dass im
innern der tee trinken überlebten
gefährt mit bauen kann jemand in den
kommentaren erklären was das bedeutet
also ihnen dafür haben gerne bahn so
leute wir sind hier bei unserem letzten
typischen angelangt es ist weihnachten
wir müssen wieder in mode kam es ist
weihnachten ich gerne einen
adventskalender und mach das letzte
türchen auch noch mal vater
also wir hatten ja softtouch karamell
und jetzt ist es oft ins news karamell
also ok man kann ja sachen doppelten
packen aber also ich brauche ich zwei
mal falsch was kostet unseren race 2009
nicht richtig feines englisch ich liebe
ja ich wundere mich nur das ist noch mal
drin ist kann er gleich machen wie
schmeckt
ich schmecke keine unterschiedlichen
bestimmt schmeckt das viel weshalb das
andere ok also die produkte sind zum
teil richtig kreativ was ich cool findet
mag immer wenn ich meinen horizont ein
bisschen erweitern kann ich muss jetzt
aber allerdings sagen ich bin ein
bisschen enttäuscht weil man merkt das
ist eigentlich ein brandnooz
adventskalender ist und sally einfach
nur ihren namen drauf gepackt also der
einzige teil der von sally kommt sind
ein paar rezepte zu ein paar produkten
und die verpackung einen chips was haben
jetzt eigene chips mit sex zu tun oder
rote beete stück hier
ich glaube nämlich dass man bei
brandnooz ein abo abschließen kann und
dann immer neue produkte zugeschickt
bekommt und so fühlt sich auch der
adventskalender an also sind halt neue
produkte wo es auch für die spaß macht
aber auch produkte wo ich mich irgendwie
ja okay also das bett kalendern lohnt
sich auf jeden fall vom preis
leistungsverhältnis hätte mich wirklich
gefreut wenn ein paar serienprodukte
dazwischen gewesen wären oder wenn sally
einfach ohne bränden
und alleine einen adventskalender
gemacht hätte mit ihren sally produkt
ich glaube das hätte ihr viel mehr
gebracht und das wäre viel cooler
gewesen auch weil man den
adventskalender ja kauft wenn man ein
safe ennis ich bin ein fan von sell list
orten welt und möchte halt wenn ich eine
art kalender von ihr bestelle das da hat
produkte drin sind gehalt ausschließlich
nur mit sally potter welt zu tun haben
da werden die produkte aus ihrem shop
einfach perfekt gewesen also ich hatte
mich jetzt gefreut über bach trend spray
und von dort und tricks ausstechen und
sowas das ist jetzt einfach nur das
filmkonzept von brandnooz werbung für
neue produkte machen bist du was ich
meine ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen
dass herr li versucht irgendwie den
leuten das geld aus der tasche zu ziehen
ich glaube einfach dass die idee von
diesem adventskalender besser war als
jetzt die umsetzung musik leider sagen
aber trotzdem süße sache ich glaube dass
freuen sich ganz sicher ganz viele
darüber wenn sie diesen adventskalender
auspacken ich hoffe euch hat dieses
adventskalender an boxen gefallen und
wenn ja dann zeigst mir mit einem daumen
nach oben abonniert main kanal um keine
videos mehr zu verpassen aktiven die
glocke und keller - mehr zu verpassen
droht bei der glocke auf immer melden um
keine minute verpassen setzt euch für
meine wohnung um keine videos mehr zu
verpassen keine einladung bitte sucht
nicht mein haus ich liebe privatsphäre
bis dann und ich meine das ist den kamin
ich muss aber sagen als dieser bieten
kann ich das heuer für
weihnachtsgeschenke sind gebrauchen dann
gilt